over the years the sniper elite series
has given players the ability to truly
see inside the minds of fascist forces
from world war ii
these games have worked through each
title to expand the tools customization
and play styles that you can use and
sniper elite 5 continues to build on
those ideas even further we spent two
hours shooting nazis in their naughty
bits on one fairly expansive level and
here's the good and the bad from our
preview hit that subscribe button give
us the old thumbs up and let's get to it
sniper elite 5 so far has a decent list
of sniper rifles submachine guns and
pistols a few of them lean experimental
and developers said they're working with
among other places the royal armories
notorious for debunking the realism of
video game guns on our channel with our
firearms expert react series we'll have
to get jonathan's reactions to these
weapons for better or worse these world
war ii guns have many customization
options and you can go find workbenches
on each level and tinker with them that
means you aren't stuck with the weapons
you load in with and can adapt your
playstyle mid mission most of the
customization feels pretty tasteful with
more period appropriate stocks raps and
scopes and suppressors which okay they
were not so common at that time this
will be good for players just looking to
have fun and don't get too distracted by
the idea of customization in world war
ii if you're more of a weapons purist a
few things might bother you front grips
do seem kind of just glued on there and
there's a variety of ammo types
including non-lethal bullets think metal
gear just very gamey we didn't see
anything else egregious though like red
dot sights guns now have iron sights
making it easy to go between precision
and a wider field of view for better
awareness although i found them to be
just a tad fiddly using a controller
this is something i could probably have
fixed in the menu and not an issue with
mouse and keyboard outside of weapons
there's a bunch of characters you can
unlock by playing through the game the
reason for this level of customization
is the game's desire to open up a lot of
different play styles in the
presentation developers said they're
going for a big sandbox where you could
do things like sit back and snipe do run
and gun stealth or just go in weapons
blazing if you want to try that we
attempted all of these styles and some
worked out better than others the level
we played occupied residents is pretty
massive with lots of different terrain
like farmland underground bunkers and a
huge compound the map also has a good
amount of vertical space with vines to
climb and zip lines for traversal the
main thing that stands out about
occupied residents are mechanics that
add replayability the level had multiple
starting places that you could find and
unlock it had routes that you could
discover and open up in multiple ways
there was also lore and intelligence
that give you optional side targets and
even some mysteries and puzzles for
example you might find a chest on one
side of the level and then the crowbar
to open it on the other side or you
might find a bunker that you can blow
open loudly or go find the guard that
has the key so you can open it without
alerting enemies at one point i blew
open a wall safe never quite found out
what was in it because i got swarmed
right after that and it was nowhere near
any objective that was my biggest
takeaway from this level there's a lot
to discover and it feels like it was
almost designed like hitman for you to
replay it over and over and perfect your
runs and that takes us back to
non-lethal ammo i'm willing to bet there
are non-lethal playthroughs and
achievements associated with it in
general they're now just a host of
non-lethal options and those takedowns
are fun they're even more effective
sometimes than guns and it's pretty
satisfying to whistle at an enemy get
their attention draw them over and then
drop a haymaker
on the hitman esque front there are
plenty of environmental kills too like
dropping chandeliers and supplies on
people there's also a huge variety of
red things to explode and the ability to
mine or booby trap both vehicles and
down soldiers
when it came to enemies the ai in this
preview was a mixed bag the way i
remember it i went back and played
sniper elite four so don't quote me on
this but you could pretty much do
whatever you wanted within confined
areas and the rest of the map wouldn't
get alerted in elite 5 there's still
section off places but also roving
patrols and once you go past a certain
alert level larger portions of the map
seem to come to life become far more
aggressive and chase you down some areas
didn't appear to be clearable at all
with a loud approach and enemies either
seemed to respawn or there were just too
many of them it was hard to tell the
really cool part of larger enemy map
awareness though is your ability to
manipulate where they go with careful
planning or in my case accidental
planning in one run i set up a mine very
early on and then like 20 minutes later
when i'd forgotten about it i was being
cornered by enemy troops and it went off
all the soldiers chasing me then ran to
the other side of the map and i got away
where enemy ai falls apart a bit was
once the map has gone into two high
levels of alarm huge packs of enemies
would just sort of rove into your area
and usually find you the game didn't do
as good a job at communicating how they
knew exactly where you were typically in
the sniper elite series there's a ghost
image that shows your last known
position and that's where they go but
there was really no way to know where
these giant packs of soldiers would roam
so you would usually get discovered
another place the difficulty in ai
didn't really work as well were indoors
where the cramped camera made it hard to
know exactly when it was safe to round a
corner or enter a room without being
immediately seen on the bright side you
can actually use this to your advantage
like funneling multiple bad guys into
doorways or calling them over to the
same set of bushes and repeatedly
knocking them out
one soldier ran right in front of me to
check out a decoy i just put down and
completely ignored me standing right
there again some of this is just to let
players have fun it's not necessarily
game breaking it's just something to
consider another behavior i don't
remember seeing in other sniper elite
games as much although again my
experience is more limited so tell me if
i'm wrong is multiple enemy injury
states wounded enemies would lay on the
ground and continue to spot you or
stumble around a bit after being hit it
was really cool and i felt kind of bad
in some cases for not making a clean
kill in summary the enemy of the game is
great most of the time but could
probably use some tweaks at higher alert
settings the sniping part of sniper
elite is as fantastic as ever with those
signature free anatomy lessons you get
each killcam i was able to use terrain
and the environment to great advantage
including taking out a truck driver and
then hiding out under the vehicle to
shoot down a road
there are also a decent number of
materials you can shoot through but that
cuts both ways so if you go hide in say
a tower enemies can blast through the
wood and still get you there are
multiple ammo types that play into the
system with advantages and disadvantages
armor piercing can go through metal and
stone soft points do far more damage to
troops but can't go through helmets or
wood and subsonic rounds are quieter
with less of a chance to alert but also
do less damage then there's match ammo
that has less bullet drop and
non-lethal as mentioned before the
unlock tree is fairly robust for this
kind of game there's three categories
which are combat equipment and body i
immediately went to one that lets you
pull out your pistol when you're in a
down state and it saved me multiple
times it's an unlocked tree that seems
more accommodating to a wide variety of
playstyles notice the theme going here
like more aggressive players or stealth
players i'd have to spend more time with
it to see how truly useful it is you are
pretty powerful from the start and the
game is forgiving already allowing you
to self-revive as long as you have a med
pack so again this all feels designed to
open up multiple runs of each map at
higher and higher difficulty levels
the sound design and music are really
excellent the game felt like a caper
with music swelling at the right times
or adding suspense when you were
sneaking it was really cool and when you
shoot a rifle that sound wave travels
off into the distance it's just really
satisfying
the other thing to mention is i spotted
an invasion phone which is used to give
you hints at where an invading player
kind of like dark souls might be but we
didn't actually get to see this mode yet
the plot isn't worth spending a lot of
time on kind of boils down to stop nazi
from getting super weapon and that's not
really what sniper elite players come to
this series for anyway it's just all
about that long range shooting the
mission that we played though was the
second mission with the game taking
place around d-day d-day happening
somewhere in the middle of the plot
sniper elite 5 is out on may 26th and
gamespot has a lot more coverage to go
of this and other shooter titles head on
over to gamespot and gamespot's youtube
page for firearms expert reacts
weaponless videos and our thoughts on
what's going on on major titles like
call of duty battlefield and fortnite
which is still good all right thanks for
watching
you